[Music]
we wanted to do something special first
this is a huge honor we don't do this
often you see on the show we do a thing
called puppy Conan where we recreate our
show using adorable puppies well in
honor of the Big Bang Theory's 200th
episode we've given your show the puppy
treat analysis this is probably the
greatest honor you'll ever receive a
life illness ladies and gentlemen it's
time to reveal puppy Big Bang Theory
let's get them in here
[Applause]
and puppy Leonard right there it's an
exact recreation there's puppy Howard
puppy Lana the apartment feels a little
empty Leonard Howard could use some
company so please welcome puppy penny
and puppy show then let's get puppy
penny and puppy Sheldon in here very
nice of course we need the rest the gang
let's bring in puppy Bernadette puppy
Amy and puppy Raj Plus just for fun
special guest stars puppy Larry King and
puppy flava flav let's get popularity
[Applause]
really should be part of your path think
about it that's an episode to the right
let's do it
yeah we'll take a break much more with
the Big Bang Theory cast in the second
stick around